uh in the Women's World Cup it's called
The Women's World Cup we have a new
Superstar the Canada midfielder Quinn
goes by the name Quinn wasn't the name
that Quinn was born with but Quinn has
been heralded celebrated this week as
the first transgender non-binary
footballer to play in the Women's World
Cup to which my response when I read
this was I got a second hang on is she
is she a butt is she they whatever is
she a biological male no no turned out
she's a biological female she so so what
is she well whatever they'd like to go
let's go hang on hang on
today and Quinn I haven't answered I
haven't asked the question here she's a
they she is a transgender non-binary
what is that well how can you be
transgender and non-binary because
that's what they are but non-binary
meant you and neither one nor the other
Queen also is is sorry so I thought
transgender meant you you literally okay
male to female female to male turns out
the non-binary is not the same as
transition I don't want to put words in
their mouth but I would say that's
probably because they're not allowed to
take the correct amount of testosterone
because they are still playing in the
women's team and so I would assume they
are saying testosterone doesn't want to
be okay that's what I'm saying sorry
Quinn doesn't want to be male because
Quinn can't compete Queen is he female
playing against females but now doesn't
want to identify because you won't let
her play on the male team
she doesn't want to play on the male
team she doesn't she's not actually they
might Quinn might like know that Quinn
wants to be a an ex-woman Alex hang no
no stop being mean by interrupting I'm
coming I'm coming to Alex effect that's
when you get my head around this she's a
transgender non-binary ex-woman so my
question is if you're no longer
identifying as a woman what are you
doing playing in the Women's World Cup
not my title that is the official title
of a tournament she doesn't qualify they
they don't qualify even there's only one
of them they don't qualify for the
Women's World Cup because they used to
be a woman but now they don't want to be
a woman so now we have to call them they
for being a transgender even though
they're non-binary and they're still
playing in the Women's World Cup and
we're all supposed to go well done Quinn
what a moment
we're celebrating with Alex what are we
celebrating rules change all the time
it's like we're bestowing upon people
who have gender dysphoria some sort of
magical extra special power that normal
people don't have and I don't care
frankly how many scores have they how
many goals have they scored you know
that's more interesting if you're a
professional Paula why is somebody why
someone who doesn't consider themselves
a woman in the Women's World Cup explain
to me because where else are they going
to be able in a trans or non-binary
tournament I don't see one and I
certainly don't I keep being told there
are millions I keep being told there are
millions of trans people
so appears if you and I want to set one
up then I'm I'm all for that swimming
I've just done it today fantastic so why
don't we do that right so instead of
being out they shouldn't be competing no
I do not in Queensland no I do not
accept that what options did this person
have none was my answer none no options
did this person yes to perform on their
work what a wonderful places you both
know this is such no you do be angry
people look at your faces
why are you not angry why are you not
angry to protect and Applause why don't
you want to protect women why is it
always left to me to protect women
aren't protected they're not this person
has gone and they've won an Olympic
medal and now they are playing
successfully doesn't want to be a woman
I don't see what the problem is
my understanding is they've not had any
sort of testosterone so there's no
biological
thing in in the sport I don't care stop
telling us all about your great moves to
be a transgender non-binary whatever
nobody cares
um tell me what I do care about the boss
of NatWest Alison Rose has now admitted
in this Nigel farage Coots Bank Fiasco a
serious error of judgment tells that she
admits she sat next to the top BBC
journalist the night before the BBC
journalist tweets the real story about
Nigel farage is that actually it wasn't
to do with his political views that he
was removed from a Coots account it was
because of his financial situation turns
out to be a total lie because Nigel
farage got under the data rules he got
all the minutes from the meeting where
it was clearly his his political views
hey whichever side you're on on this
politically makes no difference to me
I've got no truck to support farage at
all he's trying to stiff me over Donald
Trump as I've said as I said he's got a
lot of pain jumping his way for that so
that's a different Feud rumbling away
however on this I'm
right come on have you got one of these
on me and I was told I'm not a
politically whatever it is person so
they haven't they assured me but they've
had a lot of calls from clients asking
am I am I next for this right what have
you got on me is it my political views
what are you holding on me this is not
right in a democracy like this that
people's political opinions lead to them
having their bank account canceled it's
just not okay let's just can we make one
thing Crystal Clear which is that Coots
is a very selective bank so it you know
Nigel farage was offered a bank account
with now not with kids he wasn't going
to be just thrown out I mean I can't go
and get a bank account with Coots you
know they are very selective and but but
however her briefing the CEO briefing uh
the BBC business journalist is apps
extraordinary I mean I mean to me I
can't understand how you can talk about
someone's financial matters totally
agree I don't understand all on that
alone it's just a massive breach of his
business and I have to say and it's it's
on the record now you called it last
week peers right when we discussed this
you did yeah um and you're absolutely
right to have said what you did last
week because it makes it it's it's just
uncomfortable whichever way you look at
it completely wrong whether it's
somebody in the street or Nigel farage
or the queen I mean the queen used to
bounce down the street though let's talk
about this in proportion
I read through every word of of their
meeting and Alex the truth is you know
Nigel well the truth is there was not
nothing in there other than apparently
you knew Donald Trump he liked Novak
djokovic's tweet I mean the whole thing
was ridiculous but I mean it's a
personal Vendetta isn't it and the
problem and what we've actually found
out since Nigel told the world about
this story is this is happening to
countless normal people yeah and it's
it's it's really quite dystopian it's
worrying it's like the Chinese social
credit system believe what we believe or
you can't have access also you've got to
trust your bank right how can somebody
who runs one of the biggest banks in the
country brief to a journalist inaccurate
serious information
correct something which is that the
reason that some people are being turned
away from bankstown is because they want
to deal in cash and banks no longer want
to deal in cash that is entirely
different from political views we've got
two different stories here that are
getting a little bit that's a different
issue no but if we're going to say that
we should clear issue here is if you
have certain opinions it should not be
down to a bank to decide your opinions
don't suit their values it's nonsense
to be fair I do get to choose who I bank
with so for example I'm aware of One
bank I think it's the cooperative bank
if they still do that we're very clear
around an advertising campaign about how
they would invest your money
um in environmentally friendly for
example projects that's a good thing and
I can choose whether I want to bankrupt
the co-op or not they should also have
the opportunity to decide whether they
want me hold on if this was if this is
when this is on the Bakery Korean Island
says I don't want to bake a game
by the way this has happened to Jeremy
we're here this happened to Jeremy
corbyn you might just imagine what would
have happened if Cooter said I don't
want to bank with you because you're
white or I don't want to bank or you do
you to bank with us because you're gay
then of course we're having a different
conversation
[Music]
to that case all right and we all agreed
though that this boss should probably
not be in her job yeah she should
Shuffle us it's definitely it's
definitely a grievance issue and I'll be
agree that as a result uh unlike the
theme of Barbie women shouldn't really
be put in top jobs
because they just they just can't be
trusted
[Applause]
tonight I actually think Sadiq Khan's on
to something there because when I'm with
my Village mates we do sometimes if
somebody crosses a line it's
inappropriate someone will go may come
on it is actually quite a good little
certainly in The Villages mates come on
you're defending City car yeah I've
agreed with him twice running last night
about pollution he's bang on about
pollution ever since he got air purifier
miles I'm a different Beast yeah
honestly yeah transformed my health just
living in a very polluted area in London
I now have air purifiers don't go out
when the Air's bad and and I feel great
and until everyone is out there he's got
problems with red eyes streaming signers
all that stuff you think maybe hay fever
I bet it's pollution go and get air
purifiers shut the windows only go out
when your app tells you to trust me
you'll feel exactly like I do I'm gonna
get pairs of just stop oil
good to see you